مسؤول امريكيون رفيع المستوى كشف ان
المنطاد الصيني تم استهدافه بامر من
الرئيس جو بايدن وذلك من قبل مقاتله من
طراز اف 22 تابعه للقياده الشماليه
الامريكيه التي اطلقت الصاروخا واحدا من
دون وقوع اضرار جانبيه او ضرر للمدني
والمنطاد بدات بعد ان قضت ثمانيه ايام في
السفر الى نورس كارولينا
قبل اسقاطه فوق المحيط الاطلسي
في البدايه دخل المنطاد الصيني منطقه
التعريف الجوي الامريكيه وتحديدا باحدى
جزر الاسكا في الثامن والعشرين من يناير
ثم دخل الى المجال الجوي الكندي في
الثلاثين من يناير حيث ساهمت كندا في
عمليه التتبع المنطاد الصيني وفق
البنتاجون ليعاود الدخول الى المجال الجوي
الامريكي مره اخرى وهو يشق طريقه الى
السماء فوق مدينه
مونتانا ومن ثم الى ولايه اينهوفو في
الحادي والثلاثين من يناير ليتم بعد ذلك
اسقاط المنطقه الصيني على بعد سته اميال
اي ما يعادل 9.6 كم من ساحل ساوث كارولينا
الامريكيه فيما يمتد حجم الحطام على مساحه
سبعه اميال ما يعادل 11.2 كيلو متر